hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well the OMA the wise
ancient woman who Socrates as a young
man is studying with about love promises
to initiate him into the deeper
mysteries of love and here in this topic
we're going to see her doing precisely
that Socrates has confessed his
ignorance he is now ready to learn
something deeper about the nature of
love itself and diamo begins by talking
about us all being poets we'll come back
to that in just a moment why is that
important well because something that's
involved in poetry or any sort of making
any sort of production is a desire for
the good every desire that we have
ultimately is for some sort of good or
even that thing that we call happiness
and so love desires the good and it can
steer us in a lot of different pathways
let's actually take a look at some of
the examples that she gives of poetry
she says we use the word for the people
who engage in rhyme and meter if I say
poet you might actually think about
somebody sitting around a coffeehouse
you know doing poetry slams
probably somebody who's fairly you know
fairly different than most of the other
people particularly in the way they
dress or affectations you know let's say
we put aside the sort of pejorative
notion of poet we talk about great
poetry it's still something that we
consider to be purely literary and even
if we extend it to the cultural sphere
and we say well look you know the Greek
dramatic poets were the forerunners of
our film industry or things like that
it's still a limited segment of society
the Ottoman says that in a certain sense
everybody's a poet he says we give
various names to the various arts we
call one poet tree but there's all these
other arts that are tied in with it as
well
business athletics philosophy we don't
call these people poets but they really
are why because they're involved in some
sort of process of making some sort of
production some sort of seeking they are
all motivated by some sort of desire
some sort of love for the good and they
visualize or they represent the good in
different ways so the person who's in
finance and is devoted to making money
that's in part because they think that
that is actually going to make them
happy or make their family happy if that
matters to them or get them prestige if
that's what matters to them all of them
are involved in some process of seeking
making loving doing and so love love
really desires to possess the good for
ever it desires the good not in the way
that can be satisfied at a particular
point in time or even a number of
different points in time it wants the
good to be its own its possession for as
long as the desire is going to exist we
could say for eternity if the desire
thinks of themselves as existing in
eternity you might say our desire
extends itself beyond the purely
presence the even the realm of countable
time and space to encompass the all the
the eternal so a lot of desires to
possess the good forever
and Socrates can understand this this
fits in with the sort of moral
perspective that he has and many other
philosophers have but now he gets sort
of stuck and you own him and he has to
help him out
so she says well what is what does that
lead to how does this take place
he says she says love really just
desires to bring forth to bring to birth
to produce a kind of of progeny upon or
in the beautiful
that's the secret message that that's
there she says we're not actually
looking for our other half we're looking
for a unity that surpasses that and we
can only do that within something that
is beautiful so Socrates says that's
really deep I don't understand what
you're talking about and she says I'll
try to explain it a little bit more
plainly she says we're all of us fertile
prolific in a body and in soul and when
we reach a certain age the Venus takes
the form of sexual desire a desire to
engage in reproduction so if we go over
now now and look at here we can talk
about birth in the body we have a desire
to have sex and it's not just a desire
to engage in pleasure or make a need go
away or even you know we could think of
other things that draw people in you
know need for social approval or
approval that one person there's
something deeper going on there and what
do Thomas says that it is is something
that she says goes on within the whole
of the realm that reproduces itself what
we want is a sort of limited immortality
animals reproduce themselves and
therefore reproduce their kind their
species they make more new animals right
and they don't look exactly like them
and they don't have exactly the same
temperaments there are different kinds
of beings but they're not
radically different so you know cats
make a whole bunch of kittens pump dogs
make a whole bunch of puppies elephants
make I think Casas is what they call
them right and we can go on with that
human beings likewise those who are as
she says pregnant in the body she's
thinking about men by the way as being
pregnant and wanting to you know in the
sexual act sort of transfer that
pregnancy to the woman who is going to
bring that that to the gestation just
men who are pregnant in the body seek
out women and they have sex with them
and they produce little kids and that
produces a family and hopefully that
family leaves behind you know
replacements for the ones who died and
also continues the family name continues
other things about them continues the
mannerisms continues the projects it's
an attempt to have a kind of immortality
and this makes a lot of sense because
both in ancient Greece and in our own
day we often see parents investing so
much of themselves and their dreams and
hopes in their children often with their
dreams and hopes that fail to by the way
they get hyper aware of the possibility
of passing on to their kids right this
can turn into a problem now this isn't
the end of the story though and there's
a lot of interesting stuff here another
point that we should actually stress is
that the Ottumwa has this digression
about the nature of knowledge as well
she's not attempting to provide a
complete epistemology at this point this
is just an example but she says think
about the thoughts in your head think
about the knowledge that you have does
it remain constant forever like it's
burned into your brain as if you're she
doesn't have this example the thing
about it this way as if you're sort of
like a motherboard that has everything
fused in know you've got all of this
knowledge and bits and pieces of it are
ending away as you as you hear this
right now and you've got to work to put
those back in there that's why we lose
skills over time that's why if we
haven't read a book for a long time we
forget exactly what happened in story
and we mix characters up and things like
that
we need to refresh that that is a an
attempt to try to
introduced a stability a fixity into
what is off and shifting and that's the
the nature of human knowledge
unfortunately that's also the nature of
physical beings you know you can't keep
the body in exactly the same state I
mean think about it they didn't know
that cellular biology at that time but
the entire body is constantly in flux
and change there's not a single cell in
your body so so you know the scientists
tell us that was living you know at the
time that you were born except maybe you
know who knows maybe eggs are that way
but most of them are completely new
cells right so that's the way it works
with the body there's this process of
reproduction people who are pregnant in
the body produce more kids that's
wonderful but that's not as high as love
can go that's the lesser understanding
of love that's the lesser activity of
love that's the lesser poetry of love
those who are pregnant to the soul those
who are attracted to higher things that
are not merely of the body you have the
potential for a immortality that's not
merely having a repetition of the same
or the similar but they can tie
themselves in with eternity in a real
tangible way according to Plato those
who are pregnant in the soul they bring
forth something different as their
product as their poetry they bring forth
wisdom and the other virtues and she has
a description here of how this actually
works for the young person who becomes
aware of this think about puberty right
puberty is a time of great upheaval in
your life or at least it should be if
you're having normal reactions because
you get flooded with all these hormones
and some of those hormones say you know
let's fall in love let's have sex let's
do this let's do that
some people are attracted to things that
are higher to things that are greater
deeper more encompassing so she says the
here
if any man is so closely allied to the
divine to be teeming with these virtues
to brought forth these virtues in his
youth when he comes to manhood his first
ambition is to be beginning to reproduce
you can be sure he will go about in
search of the loveliness on which he may
be get now what kind of loveliness is
that going to be a loveliness of the
soul not a loveliness of the body it is
attracted by a beautiful body but if he
finds a soul that's beautiful
distinguished and agreeable
he's so charmed to find so welcome and
alliance it will be easy for him to talk
a virtue to such a listener and it is
discuss what human goodness is and how
the virtuous should live to undertake
the others education the others
upbringing
just like the those who are pregnant in
the body have to raise their children
something similar happens in friendships
or in the love relationship that has
been talked about you know in this we
might think about do demise doing
something similar to this with Socrates
although it's just hinted at there isn't
it in any case it leads to these
friendships that can be completely
stable friendships over the course of a
lifetime in which people are growing
together these are things that will not
be completely understandable to those
who are on this level they'll be like
why are you hanging out with that person
they're not very attractive they don't
have a lot of money they can't really
open doors for you and so well they're a
really great person I like the kind of
person that I am with them I'm becoming
a better person by being with them some
people are just aren't going to get that
people who are able to get that have the
potential to be up here
perhaps in I guess the tragic thing is
that so many have that potential and
don't do anything with it now Socrates a
rather do Noma goes on Socrates is
narrating dota is talking in this to
tell us about two greater ways in which
the soul can be pregnant and bring forth
amazing wonderful not just life changing
but world-changing children she talks
about the poet's she brings up home
and Hesiod and just think about how many
other authors we have that we you know
look to and say you know in a certain
sense the world is different after the
publication of their works you know
because of the death because of the
profundity of them I mean Homer is one
of them Hesiod I'm a little bit if he
him but think about Dostoevsky think
about Solzhenitsyn you know after the
publication of The Gulag Archipelago
which isn't intended to be a work of
beauty there's something that's changed
thinking about the works of Plato
himself think about Aristotle think
about all these these people that we can
compare not all men by the way I think
about you know Mary Wollstonecraft is a
particularly good example of a woman who
does some interesting things in these
respects in any case the poet's the the
producers of cultural artifacts we could
say the producers of the things that
mirror the world and show us ourselves
they produce immortal children do nama
says and then even more important than
them according to Plato according to do
Democritus Socrates are no longer burrs
they bring forth spiritual children as
well but their spiritual children are
not just virtues not just you know you
know arrangements of
poetic verse or something like that they
do their artwork within the fabric of
society itself with the laws with the
Constitution's under which people live
with the entire society as their canvas
as their marble on which they work and
Plato you know suggest us who would not
want to be the the person coupled with
one of these people and help bring forth
beautiful great world-changing children
like that this is so much higher than
the mere reproduction even you know with
family affection even with all the other
things that go along with that that
happens at the level of the body
so all of this is is what do Tamiya is
calling one of the greater mysteries of
love in loving we become poets we
you want to bring forth something we
want to create that's what really lies
at the heart of love